I think I would have enjoyed um Colorado
mall if I didn't [ __ ] up when I got
there why what happened oh yeah so yeah
so throughout this entire uh tour we had
a lot of like spare hours like it'd be
an hour here an hour there yeah and I
would just play TFT uh Team fight Connor
was addicted I would just play it
because I didn't know like it was a lot
of the times we would have like two
hours free and you can't really leave
the venue yeah you can't really do
anything so I'm like okay I'll just play
two games of TFT so I was playing Team
fight tactics I started like bronze and
I finished the tour like diamond two it
was like driving like a madman right and
uh I was just playing a lot of games and
I'm enjoying it whatever and uh in
Colorado
um we got to the hotel I had like an
hour an hour and a half before I was
gonna go and meet up with gone so I was
like yeah okay I'll uh I'll I'll run the
bathtub and I'll play a game right oh
yeah
so so I I go to the bathtub and I you
know because a lot of the times I'm like
you know you have to run the bath and it
takes forever to fill yeah so I run the
bath and then I go to play this TFT game
I'm playing it and bear in mind I've
been trying to get diamond for a while
right and this is my Diamond promo game
right so if I win this if I get top four
I get I get diamonds what a price to pay
yeah so so I'm I'm playing this game
right and it's going well and I'm I'm
literally there's five of us left so I
need to get fourth to place and I'm
doing it I'm and I'm finally I'm in the
line I'm in the the round against the
main me Fifth and fourth or on like one
health bar each so if whichever one of
us wins this fight we we win yeah and so
I'm playing it right and I I just about
just about beat this guy and I finished
fourth and I get my [ __ ] 10 points
and I'm [ __ ] happy popping off I'm
like [ __ ] yes yes and then on the door
here
uh oh okay and so I get up off the bed
and as I put my foot down on the carpet
I hear like a like a Squish and it's not
like a like a light little squish it's a
deep squish like water envelops my foot
yeah oh oh [ __ ] and I see because the
beds here and the hallway goes around
like this and I just see wet going all
the way around right right to the door
I'm like what the [ __ ] so I run in the
bathtub I turn it off and prior to this
I checked that the bathtub had like the
drains so that it like overflowed like
things so it wouldn't overflow and it
had them but clearly they weren't
[ __ ] work right so and then I quickly
pulled the plug realized a plug doesn't
basically work like it doesn't unplug
you have to prop something in there to
keep it up right yeah it's like one of
those ones stuck in yeah and so it won't
prop up and I'm trying everything I'm
trying to [ __ ] empty it you know I'm
like hearing yeah on my door and I'm
like [ __ ] okay so I I empty this bathtub
or try to and it's emptying so slowly
yeah yeah
um and I opened the door and I just see
that from my hallway I can just see a
wet patch going around bear in mind this
is 30 minutes of a bathtub yeah it did
this much damage right so I'm like oh
[ __ ] I'm sorry and I'm thinking [ __ ] I
can't say I was playing League of
Legends
I can't say that's the reason why this
happened uh so she's like what happened
I'm like I I ran a bathtub and I fell
asleep I'm so sorry I've been really
tired yeah and she was like oh okay okay
um I'm gonna go and call the engineers
so I wait in this damp room I'm like
shoveling the water because the the
bathroom's tiled yeah so I'm just
shoveling the water into the sink yeah
trying to get rid of all this water in
the bathroom right yeah I managed to get
rid of most of it
um again I don't know how on Earth
there's this much capacity this is much
volume of water that was generated in 30
minutes it's insane yeah um and then the
engineers come one of them's like super
Southern Sound he goes golly this is
crazy and he goes I'm like I'm like yeah
man I I'm so sorry like what the heck
happened here yeah I was like yeah I
fell asleep I ran the bathtub and he's
like all right well they're telling me
they're like yeah just go down to the
front desk and uh tell them that you you
flooded your room and you're right yeah
and I was like [ __ ] how she's gonna
[ __ ] cost me bro this is gonna cost
me so so much [ __ ] money so
I go down and I'm like hey yeah I'm the
guy who flooded this room can I have a
new room like yeah yeah sure no worries
all right oh like remember like
beratement right yeah she I'm like I'm
sorry sorry this is a complete action I
mean to do this she's like oh no no
don't worry yesterday somebody flushed
that toilet all the [ __ ] went to the
floor below and I was like I was like
what she's like yeah it's an old
building this [ __ ] happens all the time
I'm like what okay they seem really
chill about it they were like they made
me feel like I did nothing I'm like I'm
gonna flood another hotel room why are
you floating in your hotel room amateur
I'm gonna load another game
this is awesome
um you know and so I I get the keys I go
to the new room and I wanted I wanted to
take a bath death even though I wasn't
scared I was determined and it was like
some Cosmic intervention had come
because there wasn't even a plug so I
couldn't even take them out they
purposely put you in their room to be
like
I was like he ain't taking a bath man
bad things happen I brought in my hand I
was like I wonder if this should have
been a problem that kept happening where
like because none of the Overflow things
worked yeah this is flooded before where
they were like just don't like to have
bats I might grow for you am I gross for
wanting to take a bath in a U.S Hotel
absolute [ __ ] lutely but I just
wanted to soak in it I just wanted to
relax yeah and so I I I was like no I'm
taking a bath and I got one of the hand
towels and I clogged it and blocked the
drain so I could have a bath just enough
so the water wouldn't leave yeah and
then when I was done pulled it all out
had my bath successful was should I have
been deterred from plugging the bath
after flooding one room absolutely yes
no you didn't flood one room you flooded
three rooms right so yeah so so it was
it was interesting because um I got a
message from my Lane who obviously David
must have told so one of my members are
told and then I kept hearing Chinese
Whispers versions of my own story and
then they were like I heard he broke the
whole hotel it was like no I heard he
flooded four floors I'm like no I heard
four people
what actually happened was uh not that
you guys ever heard an alternative story
is that I FL I not flooded the room next
to me got really [ __ ] wet and the
room below me got really wet so three
rooms in total my room the room next to
me and the room
guys
four floors I didn't flooded three rooms
guys four floors is way more dramatic
come on that's like the entire
Foundation is [ __ ] right so uh it
caused that much property
the room next door was available by the
end of the day they just did a blow dry
the floor with this giant [ __ ] thing
because like because what happened was
is later about an hour later after this
all happened I went back to look at the
scene of the crime yeah because I wanted
to see the damage right I wanted to see
how bad it was it was all dry right by
an hour an hour and a half later because
I had this giant [ __ ] heat thing yeah
clearly this has happened before oh yeah
one of these things it was it was drying
the carpet and the carpet was all dry
yeah and I was like oh all right and
then and then I I was like what's the
what's the damage now like well if
there's anything we'll let you know yeah
and uh they and so I heard back from
them yet no oh [ __ ] no so I still
haven't had to pay anything he's just
like I'm in Japan now
bro I was I was about to fight like I
was about to become Better Call Saul if
you're like your honor the bathtub
should have drained there was a drain
and it wasn't working clearly an
engineering yeah clearly a flaw on the
design of this bathtub and this was an
accident waiting to happen
Okay
no I was about to say the cherry on top
of this entire [ __ ] cake it's just the
fact that this happened because you're
playing [ __ ]
I think you can't make that [ __ ] I think
I think my favorite reaction because I
was like I was actually like in a bar
because we were ironically enough worlds
like 2022 was going on and we were like
I was like there was a game going on I
was like Connor you want to come to this
bar and watch some league with me and so
our tour manager was going to join us as
well
um and I'd heard that because the room
was booked under her name yeah she had
heard that uh that's you know one of her
talents that she was taking care of had
fell asleep in the bathroom so then they
again this kept the story kept changing
apparently I I'd fallen asleep in the
bathtub
so she was like panicking being like Oh
my God Connor you okay you hurt are you
like oh you did anything happen and he
was like yeah I was uh no no no no no
she goes oh my God what happened to you
okay and I chose her back I'm like yeah
what's up
and I was uh playing League of Legends I
was like she was like I heard you felt
super better man I texted her I'm like
yeah so I was actually playing League of
Legends and I lied because I didn't want
to seem like I was an absolute [ __ ]
idiot
but that's what happens you know you
grab you grab the dog in League of
Legends yeah you took an immediate nail
but they were very cute they were very
kind about it again all the hotel staff
were super chill about it and I really
appreciate it I just want to know what
kind of [ __ ] happens on a daily basis in
that hotel if this is something that's
like yeah whatever I'm minor
inconvenience I'm sure the weirdest
[ __ ] [ __ ] goes down hotels
every Hotel manager has like a [ __ ]
story oh bro [ __ ] that has gone down in
a hotel yeah but that was fun